نحن نستخدم هذه الإستراتيجية لمدة 10 أيام من
الذكاء مثل صنع أي
يمكنك الانضمام إلى الطائرات بدون طيار نعم ولدينا
مجموعة من ثمانية أشخاص كنت رجلًا
يطير لدينا قائد ورجل كان في
الواقع فرق الأمن الخاصة بي
في  الشجيرات تشاهد فقط
حتى لا أقتلك أثناء
التحكم في الطائرة بدون طيار ، لذا فأنت تحلق بالطائرة
بدون طيار ، نعم إنهم يدعمونك نوعًا
ما
، وتفعل ذلك لمدة عشرة أيام ، نعم ،
ثم بعد ذلك تحدد نعم بالضبط
بعد ذلك لدينا هذه الخريطة ، هذه
خريطة فلاد ديمينكو لـ نوفي بكوف ، المدينة
التي نقف فيها ، صنعها باستخدام طائرته
بدون طيار ، يمكنك أن ترى أنه وضع دائرة حول الهدف
تلو الهدف بعد الهدف باللون الأحمر ،
إليكم ما يحدث بعد ذلك ندعو
طائرة بدون طيار خطيرة مثل  أولئك الذين يمكنهم البقاء في
الهواء لمدة
ساعتين وكنت أرسله معهم ، لذلك كنت أشير
إليهم مثل المكان الذي يحتاجون إليه
للطيران ولديهم اتصال
بالمدفعية وكنا نعمل على
كل هدف مثل لذلك
وضعنا أولوياتنا و  خطوة بخطوة
وأنت جو
نعم ، نوع من المرح التالي لنكون صادقين ،
نحن نقف في موقع
أول ضربة كبيرة لفلاد ، كم منهم كان
هناك ،
أعتقد أن حوالي
20 30 شخصًا 20 أو 30. نعم ، وقتل
10 منهم على الأقل
هنا  تساعد الطائرات بدون طيار في
قتل الكثير من الروس لدرجة أنه في
قرية أخرى تظهرها هنا طائرة بدون طيار CNN ،
أخبرني رجل أن الجنود الروس الذين يحتلون
منزله حصلوا على مكافآت من
علب السجائر لإسقاط طائرات بدون طيار الأوكرانية ،
فنحن نستخدم طائرات بدون طيار صينية
ويقدم الصينيون للروس برامج أه يمكن
أه ابحث فينا ، اكتشفنا حتى يرى الروس
من أين بدأنا ومن أين
نزلنا وبمجرد أن حدث لنا
أنه كان هجومًا مثل على الفور ،
فقط أه
كانت الطائرة بدون طيار تهبط والتالي مثل
في 30 ثانية  كان اللغم الأرضي كما
لو كان قريبًا جدًا مثل 30 مترًا ،
لقد كانت لحظة فلاد يقول كثيرًا مثل هذا
الذي يرون الطريق بالكامل من حيث
أطير إلى أعلى حيث هبطت كل شيء
يرونه كل شيء يرونه هاتفي
شركة صينية  هي كلاً من طائرة dji بدون طيار
التي يستخدمها
فلاد وبرنامج airoscope الذي يتتبع الكثير مما تفعله
الطائرة بدون طيار
وهذا ما يقول فلاد أن الروس
يستخدمونه لمحاربة حرب أوكرانيا بدون طيار ،
كيف يمكنك القيام بالطائرة بدون طيار في ذلك الوقت
طوال تلك الأيام العشرة والحصول عليها  جميع
المعلومات دون علمهم
الآن لدينا إستراتيجية كاملة ، لذا فأنت
تأتي أولاً ولا تقوم بتشغيل الطائرة بدون طيار
كما لو كنت تبتعد عن مجموعتك
مثل بضع مئات من الأمتار وأنت
تغادر الطائرة بدون طيار التي تشغلها عليك.  عند
العودة بعيدًا عن الطائرة بدون طيار ،
تبدأ في إنشاء حوض السباحة الخاص بك وأنت تطير على ارتفاع
منخفض جدًا مثل 10 أمتار ،
وفقط ، بجوار موقعهم ، تقوم
بإجراء بحث مثل
إنشاء الصور التي تصنع مقطع فيديو
والعودة  كما هو الحال في
اتجاهات مختلفة جدًا حتى لا يتمكنوا من
تتبعك بطريقة مباشرة الآن ، فأنا
شخصياً أعرف
أن الرجال الأحرار يُقتلون
فقط لأن
لا أحد يعرف كيف يعمل مع ذلك من
قبل وهذا هو الثمن الذي ندفعه مقابل
هذا التكتيك  يقول فلاد الآن أن هناك
طائرة أمريكية بدون طيار لا يستطيع الروس
تتبعها ، فهو يريد الكثير من هؤلاء الذين
يتصورون أنك تمتلك مشاة
، وهناك مثل حياة الرجال الذين يحتاجون
إلى الذهاب إلى القرية ، تخيل مدى
سهولة ذلك إذا كان هناك  أمامهم طائرة بدون طيار
وتخبرهم يا رفاق أن
هناك لسانًا هناك سيارة هناك
مجموعة من الأعداء على اليسار أعدوا للتو
الآن في كل فصيلة لدينا رجل
بطائرة بدون طيار واو
من المضحك أن نقول ولكن أه أكثر  من هؤلاء
الرجال الذين يستخدمون الطائرات بدون طيار هم مجرد مهووسين شباب
اعتادوا لعب ألعاب الفيديو في الوقت الحالي ،
والآن أصبحت المهارة هي نعم ، إنها
مهارة رائعة وأنت تعرف ما الذي يعجبك في
الغالب بالطبع إذا كانوا مجرد
شاب يبلغ من العمر 18 عامًا فلن يفعل أحد
أرسلهم
مثل تحرير القرى ولكن يمكنهم القيام
بعملهم وهم جالسون على بعد خمسة
كيلومترات تمامًا كما لو
كان نوعًا من المرح بالنسبة لهم
الآن ، قام نائب القائد ديمتشينكو بترقية
الرتب سريعًا
وإثبات خوض المخاطر ويتمتع بالذكاء
هنا يكافأ القائد مثل د
إذا كنت تعرف كيف تطير بطائرة بدون طيار ، فقد قلت نعم
بالتأكيد بالطبع وعندما
أعطوني طائرة بدون طيار فعلية ، كنت أحاول أن آخذه فقط
إلى المكان الذي كان
يغادر وجربه كما لو كنت على الأرجح
في ممارستك الخاصة ، نعم لم أفعل ذلك أبدًا  أنا لا
أقول لأي شخص أنني فعلت ذلك مرة واحدة فقط في
حياتي
لكنك فقط لا أعرف أنك تعلمت أثناء
الطيران ، نعم
، رائع ، أعتقد أنه مثل الشيء الرئيسي ، إنه
سهل للغاية ، الشيء الرئيسي في هذا هو
مجرد البقاء  هادئ